We say we want colleges to be more
equitable, moreaccessible.
But we tend to obsess over a
tiny group of colleges,
places like Harvard, Stanford,
Yale, Princeton,MIT.
But our cultural obsession with a limited group
ofhighly rejective colleges
has major consequences.
Regional public universities,
or RPUs for short,
are the exact opposite.
RPUs, pride themselves on accepting
everyone or almost everyone who applies.
RPU studentsare more likely to be first
generation college students like I was,
students of color,low-income students, veterans.
So when you hear someone saying,
"Oh,anyone can get into that school,"
push them on why that's a bad thing.
You don't have to be rude aboutit.
You could just say,
"Wow, that's amazing
that that school gives so manypeople
the opportunity to go to college."